I love salt igq I'm Anthony parofsky and
these are my essentials I'm obsessed
with candles I burn them all over my
apartment and when I travel I always
like to try to take one with me my
favorite brand is actually by Rado
started by a wonderful gentleman his
name is Ben Gorham and he has amazing
sense actually I don't even know which
one this is
legit and I'm gonna smell it I'm gonna
see if I can figure it out
this is either it's either vanquish or
chut no this is tri this is chai it
doesn't say it it says it in some kind
of a Sanskrit I believe but this one's
try this is one of his more recent ones
and I burn these in hotel rooms because
they make me feel like I'm at home are
they a nightmare for TSA they sure are
but are they worth it absolutely I'm
obsessed with sleep gummies by Ollie
they're melatonin
I love melatonin I first discovered it
when we were flying to Japan and I was a
terrible flyer because I'm very fearful
of flights so I pop a couple of these
with chamomile tea and it puts me right
to sleep I don't have crazy vivid
nightmares the important thing is just
to make sure that I get eight hours
because if it's less than eight hours
I'm gonna be a zombie for a few then I
have to have extra espresso and yeah
they just they make me happy because
when I have one also the taste just
tells me that it's time to go to bed
soon and sleeping is probably my
favorite hobby these are fantastic and
they make them in all different types
but melatonin is like this is my OG
I am no stranger to sense this is one
that I recently discovered it's my new
favorite it's by Dior and it's called
Albany
so basically amber of night and it
smells like amber and it kind of touches
on my polish sensibility because Polish
people are obsessed with amber jewelry
it's kind of a thing my grandmother used
to have all these necklaces and I love
the color because it kind of makes me
think of that as well but it's just
really warm and I know it's summer but
this is like a nice fall wintery scent
[Music]
in terms of jewelry and that sort of
stuff I've always been into vintage when
I was a kid when my parents would go to
Poland they would go to old markets and
they would bring back jewelry for my
sister's and I was obsessed with pocket
watches so they would bring me back old
pocket watches it didn't work and I
would wear them my dear friend Anya
introduced me to a friend of hers who's
a jeweler her name is Beth and she has a
line called foundry and they do these
incredible necklaces that are customized
with all these little pendants in these
charms the one that I'll mention is this
one is a lion which symbolizes strength
the lion has sort of become my my animal
of inspiration recently it's nice and
heavy and I just I feel like a boss when
I wear it and you know maybe it's weird
that jewelry brings you confidence but
you know what it does and it is what it
is
this is probably my single most beloved
important piece that is mine
it is my watch this is a vintage I think
it's a 19 somewhere between 1950 and
1955 Omega constellation with the
original black dial and it actually has
the gold constellation the Observatory
engraving in the back which is very rare
because they often get removed this was
gifted to me a while back so there's a
very special sort of story of
significance and where it came from
but I've been long obsessed with with
Omega watches and it actually stems from
childhood I was a swimmer
and the sort of like the what's the name
of the the clock with the chronometer
chronometer it had a symbol of Omega on
it which I didn't realize at the time
and I've always been obsessed with the
brand because of you know james bond and
i i i love everything about them because
it's something it's not only a luxury
brand but they also are so invested in
like the advancement of technology as
well it was the first watch on the moon
i love nerding out about stuff like that
but they also developed like the panels
for for swimmers during the olympics and
the counter so they'd look down so they
know how many laps they're doing so it's
so much more than a watch and it's also
just a really beautiful piece the band
on it brokes i got a really nice vintage
cordovan leather on it but i just-i I
love this thing so much and this is my
most prized possession
next up I've often said that up until
about two years ago I didn't wash my
face with soap or my hair but since I've
become quite the aficionado in skin care
and the ultimate in skin care isla
prairie skin caviar this stuff is so
decadent the bottle is beautiful I
actually only leave this in my apartment
in New York because it's something that
I have to look forward to whenever I get
to be at home it's so luxe I'm almost
done which makes me nervous
depending on my mood if I had a rough
day I'll just apply like a really thick
film and it's
it's really nice because it's not oily
it's got a pretty neutral scent it's not
perfumed and I just I feel like my best
self when I put this stuff on I love
salt the only thing I like more than
salt is to be able to travel with salt
so Jacobson which is an American brand
of salt and they do flaky finishing salt
which is really nice on salads it's nice
on a piece of fish
it has like a nice textural crunch and
this stuff is just delicious what's nice
is that you can now travel with it so if
something's not salty enough salt alone
is really great books are very important
to me I have classics that I like to
revisit I'm a big fan of Salinger this
one I've destroyed pretty much as I've
read it so many times
Franny and Zooey I think it's very
underrated a lot of people talk about
Catcher in the Rye but this is one that
everybody should read it should be
mandatory in schools actually the second
one this is actually more maybe of an
odd or an homage to my dad it's soldier
knit sins
a day in the life of Ivan Denisovich as
the grandchild of Holocaust survivors
this is something that a lot of Eastern
European kids were forced to read
growing up and I was as well and I
didn't really understand the importance
of it until I uh until I grew up it's a
man who basically worked as like he was
a prisoner of war in in Siberia and it's
one day in his life that's a really good
story and finally my number one favorite
book of all time when I was a little kid
it was read to me in Polish I learned to
read it in French when I was in school
and then I learned to read it in English
and someone very special in my life
several years ago gave me one of the
original copies and it's the little
prince and it has a lot of inspirational
quotes but also has just a really strong
message about perspective about how
depending on our perspective we can
basically decide if we're gonna have a
good day or if we're gonna have a sad
day so this is a variable that's very
near and dear to my heart
I have a stop-start
relationship with my journal I'll go
through a period of months where all
right every day and then I tend to take
a break I love it when friends give me
journals this one my sister actually got
me when she was in Turkey this is a
really old one - I kind of don't even
want to open it up because it's it's
very happy sad because I get to kind of
like look back at notes that I've taken
then see how much I've changed and how
much I haven't and I just think it's
important to write things down
especially with the crazy life that I
have now I want to remember it one day
because I forget things a lot and I
think we need to write because we're
always using computers and typing and
using our fingers and if I don't do it
often enough that I forget how to write
if I had to wear one shoe and I'm
literally wearing one shoe right now
because the second one is in my hand and
I'm about to show it to you for the rest
of my life it would be the classic Stan
Smith this one is actually in really
good condition
I had much older ones that I had
customized with writing which you can do
online
I have ham-and-cheese written in French
and popo which was my name in college
don't ask but I love these when they're
crisp and they're brand new and when
they're really aged they just they're
they're so cool when they're all really
beat up what I love about them is that
they're inexpensive they're classics and
they literally go with anything I can
wear these with trousers I can wear them
with jeans I can wear them with gym
shorts if I'm just going out on a
Saturday during the day Stan Smith's
I love sleep and I love preparing for
sleep there's just something about the
ritual just getting excited to conk out
especially these days and there's this
skincare brand called Ren and they
actually do a really cool pillow spray I
don't want to do it now because it's
gonna make me sleepy but I'm still in
space I love it it's a little bit of
lavender in there it's really it's
herbaceous and nice without being too
intense and just one little spritz on
your pillow or if you're traveling again
anything that reminds me of home I get
really excited about because I always
miss my home the ultimate luxury is
sleeping my own bed and when I can't I
get reminded of it by spraying a little
bit of this okay so my last essential
item is my cookbook coming out September
9th I'm really excited about it it's
basically an autobiography of all the
dishes that I've had from when I was a
little kid to an homage to all the women
and men in my life who made desserts
because I don't bake to my Polish
heritage to food I ate when I was a
broke student to dishes that I prepare
now for family and loved ones yeah check
it out GQ I've loved you since I was a
little kid thank you so much for hanging
out with me and watching me ramble on
about my essentials
[Music]